It takes forever to build a new thing.
Like that road you’re always driving on?
How long has that thing been under construction?
Right?
I empathize.
Now, imagine doing that one ATOM at a time.
We here at Seeker get all excited over metamaterials
because they can do so much that natural materials
can’t do like have incredible strength or
tunable conductivity.
They can have such amazing properties because
we can design and build them atom by atom,
making crystal superlattices.
The key to building these structures are artificial
atoms.
Admittedly, the name is a bit misleading,
because they’re not atoms we somehow built
proton by proton.
Rather, they’re extremely tiny crystals
made of anywhere from 100 to 10,000 atoms.
They’re still so small they experience quantum
effects, which gives them special properties
depending on their how big they are, how they're
shaped, and what they're made of.
For example spherical artificial atoms called
quantum dots glow different colors depending
on their size.
A 2 nm quantum dot gives off blue light when
excited, while a 6 nm dot glows red, even
when both dots are made of the same material.
Superlattices can be built using artificial
atoms (again, synthetic crystals) in place
of regular atoms so the structure can be really
fine tuned, but it was always thought the
process had to be a slow one.
Until, in 2016, researchers found out that
by turning up the heat they could make superlattices
in seconds instead of days.
The discovery was made quite by accident,
when researchers decided they wanted to watch
the crystals grow in real time.
So they put windows on their reaction chamber
and shined an x-ray inside.
They expected to see the beam come back all
scattered, indicating the atoms were still
arranging themselves.
Suffice it to say, that’s not what they
saw.
The researchers believe that their discovery
can be applied to a wide range of materials,
like metals, semiconductors, and more.
This could be revolutionary in the field of
metamaterials, allowing us to make these special
substances at speeds exponentially faster
than was previously thought possible.
Researchers are still trying to account for
why the crystals grow so fast, but you can
account for your finances much more easily
with Freshbooks!
FreshBooks, is an online invoicing and accounting software that lets you manage your finances or finances for a business!  You can send clean and professional looking invoices in about 30 seconds.
With literally 2 clicks you can set yourself up to receive payments online. You can even take pictures of receipts on your phone using FreshBooks’ mobile apps. This makes claiming your expenses a million times easier.
For a 30-day unrestricted trial, go to FreshBooks.com slash Seeker, and enter “Seeker” in the “How You’ve Heard About Us” section.
If you want more science news, don’t forget
to subscribe.
And for more info on how these tiny atomic
lattices are created, watch Trace’s video
here.
When the researchers made their accidental
discovery, they texted their advisor saying,
“So, something weird is happening.”
I guess that’s today’s equivalent of Eureka.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you next
time on Seeker.